bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
vidéo dédiée au gardien de la galaxie
volume 3 alors je suis désolé que cette
vidéo arrive un peu en retard ma vie
personnelle en priait un peu le dessus
par rapport à YouTube du coup cela
explique pourquoi on en parle que
maintenant mais avant que la vidéo
commence êtes-vous intéressé par la
découverte ou la redécouverte des films
Marvel depuis votre canapé chez vous par
le biais de la plateforme disney+ Marvel
Studios permet de rendre ses productions
plus accessibles par exemple Ant-Man et
la guêpe quant aux Mania qui met à
l'honneur Kang le Conquérant sorti le 15
février sera disponible sur disney+ dès
le 17 mai et pareil pour les gardiens de
la galaxie volume 3 ce dernier sera
disponible sur la plateforme dans à peu
près deux ou trois mois après sa sortie
au cinéma malheureusement vous le savez
en France il nous faut attendre au moins
un an et demi voire plus avant qu'un
Marvel soit disponible sur la plateforme
et bien il y a moyen de contourner tout
ça de manière sécurisée et efficace
grâce de notre partenariat du jour
nordvpn via cet outil en un seul clic
nortvpn vous permet de modifier votre
localisation pour faire croire que vous
êtes dans un autre pays par conséquent
si vous souhaitez voir ou revoir Ant-Man
depuis chez vous le 17 mai changer votre
localisation pour par exemple le Canada
ou les États-Unis et le tour est joué
d'ailleurs nordvpn est également un
outil rapide d'exécution grâce à sa
multitude de serveurs répartis dans plus
de 60 pays mais c'est également un outil
très sécurisé vous protégeant contre les
criminels du web et en plus de cela il
est accessible sur plus de six appareils
donc de quoi faire profiter l'entourage
si vous êtes intéressé n'hésitez pas à
accéder aux liens disponibles en
description et profitez de l'offre ses
talents sur deux ans avec une grosse
réduction et 4 mois offerts satisfaits
ou remboursés sur 30 jours merci à
nortvpn d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo
il est désormais temps de se concentrer
sur les gardiens alors que dire des
gardiens 3 et bah franchement je se
trouve le film incroyable en vous
faisant cette vidéo plusieurs jours
après du coup bah j'ai eu le temps de
redescendre d'y repenser à tête reposée
et sincèrement je trouve que nous
faisons face à un film marquant du MCU
la grande majorité du temps quand je
vais voir un film Marvel je suis
toujours plus tôt satisfait car voilà
j'aime l'univers je suis un fan de
Marvel mais une fois plusieurs jours
semaine voire mois passé bah ça m'arrive
d'oublier le film entre guillemets ou
tout simplement des fois je suis juste
en mode cahier des charges du style j'ai
une liste à cocher et je vois ce qu'ils
ont amené ce qu'ils ont modifié qu'ils
ont fait mourir les choix qu'ils ont
fait etc etc là sincèrement ce n'est pas
du tout le cas le film est très puissant
les messages sont forts l'adaptation des
personnages est là il y a eu des
modifications bien évidemment mais en
vrai pour beaucoup ça a été très comics
à querate bon déjà si nous nous sentons
comme l'a fait le film sur Rocket nous
avons retrouvé ce dont nous avions parlé
par le passé en vidéo c'est à dire la
dégradation du personnage alors
normalement dans les comics Rocket à
cause des lourdes expériences qu'il a
vécues et de sa condition de
laveur génétiquement modifié il va subir
une dégradation génétique c'est-à-dire
que son corps en vieillissant ne va pas
suivre au point que Rocket va mourir
mais au final évidemment il sera sauvé
et tout le tralala là et c'est ce que
j'aime bien avec les gardiens 3 c'est
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de respect envers
les comics mais de manière subtile dans
le sens où le film reproduit l'histoire
des comics mais comme si c'était un
détail comme si c'était secondaire par
exemple ils ont reproduit cette histoire
de Rocket mais à cause de l'intervention
d'Adam Warlock Adam à mortellement
blessé en roquette au point qu'il ne lui
reste que 48 heures à vivre et au final
les gardiens vont le sauver c'est
peut-être idiot de ma part dit comme ça
mais je trouve qu'il y a un vrai du coup
des comics tout en nous proposant du 9
et de l'innovant c'est de la bonne
adaptation je trouve on n'est pas dans
de la référence et du détail
ultra forcés où on ne voit que ça pour
que le spectateur le remarque
précisément quoi enfin bon je dis ça
mais il y en a quand même eu un petit
peu comme toujours mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler plus tard comme
prévu le MCU a décidé de relire requête
et le maître de l'évolution c'était un
move très intelligent de leur part et
bon sang les deux personnages sont
incroyables déjà Rocket ça fait du bien
d’enfin explorer son passé et
sincèrement les scènes de flashback
elles étaient lourdes émotionnellement à
regarder concernant le high évolution
Harry je suis plutôt admiratif tout
d'abord l'acteur est incroyable il a
véritablement propulsé le personnage et
ce que James gun nous a proposé le
concernant était très bien et pourtant
je vous avoue que je me demandais un peu
comment ils allaient faire en fait dans
les comics le maître de l'évolution
c'est un petit peu une entité et surtout
il n'est jamais au centre du scénario
c'est un personnage qui est capable de
s'allier au héros comme au vilain il
n'est pas spécialement puissant c'est
surtout un scientifique et possiblement
le plus grand expert de la génétique
donc c'est pour ça que c'était
intelligent comme je vous disais de le
relier à Rocket car c'était le meilleur
moyen d'en faire un véritable
antagoniste car le scénario nous
proposerait du coup une histoire
personnelle entre lui et Rocket et par
conséquent cela permettait également de
nous proposer un one shot pour le
personnage néanmoins nous avons quand
même retrouvé des thématiques très
fortes des comics pour le mettre de
l'évolution et c'est pour ça que je
trouve que l'adaptation est incroyable
le concernant tout d'abord on retrouve
ce côté d'empreinte forte entre
guillemets dans l'univers et ces
personnages dans le sens où le high
évolution Harry a marqué l'histoire
comme dans les comics avec ces
expériences où Il a orienté et façonné
plusieurs histoires de personnages et
autres super
en l'occurrence ici Rocket ou encore
Adam Warlock mais surtout ils ont bien
accentué sur la monstruosité de ces
expériences c'est quelque chose que l'on
ressent moins sur le papier car voilà
cela reste des comics des sortes de
bandes dessinées prévues pour les jeunes
lecteurs donc dans ces premières
apparitions dans les années 60-70 nous
ne sommes pas trop témoins de l'horreur
qu'il fait subir à ses créations au
contraire on est plus dans un point de
vue d'émerveillement perso quand j'ai
découvert les histoires du maître de
l'évolution j'étais plutôt dans la
fascination car en soi avec ses
créations avec la contre terre le
personnage nous présente presque un côté
divin il est une entité qui crée la vie
et l'améliore et en plus le maître de
l'évolution est quelqu'un qui a de la
prestance il est charismatique
contrairement à des personnages comme
modo par exemple qui est volontairement
affreux pour souligner le côté savant
fou donc je vous avoue que j'étais
plutôt dans la hype durant la bat au
final quand le maître de l'évolution
nous a sorti que en gros Dieu n'existait
pas et c'est pourquoi il a pris sa place
et quelle puissance de voir qu'au final
derrière son côté divin derrière son
masque il n'est qu'une abomination un
véritable savon fou car c'est quand même
ce qu'il est et qu'en plus c'est sa
création jugé imparfaites qui le fait
chuter mais bon tout le côté divin du
maître de l'évolution ne s'arrête pas
qu'à ça et pour l'expliquer il va être
temps de parler d'un personnage qui
vient de faire son arrivée et dont je
suis sûr vous voulez qu'on parle il
s'agit d'Adam worlock alors j'ai vu
beaucoup de critiques sur internet de
gens qui étaient assez déçus de
l'adaptation et de l'arrivée d'Adam
Warlock et bien moi je vais vous dire le
contraire et je vais même prendre sa
défense je trouve qu'Adam Warlock a été
très bien introduit et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi en premier lieu nous
faisons face aux mêmes critiques que
pour kangle conquérant dans quantumania
en fait je pense que beaucoup ce hyper
énormément quand ils savent qu'un
nouveau personnage censé être populaire
va faire son apparition et je le
comprends mais il faut prendre un peu de
recul sur la situation que ce soit Kang
ou Adam Warlock ce sont des personnages
qui vont devenir récurrents dans les
films du MCU par conséquent leur
histoire va s'étaler sur une multitude
de production à contrario le maître de
l'évolution lui c'est un one shot le
personnage n'est censé apparaître que
dans un film puisqu'il est censé mourir
à la fin du coup là oui il faut tout
balancer le concernant et le faire
briller mais dans le cas de Adam c'est
simplement une introduction le
personnage est très secondaire les
gardiens 3 sert simplement à justifier
sa présence et son entrée c'est plus
tard qu'il sera véritablement développé
ensuite James gun a quand même été très
respectueux des comics le concernant
même si je vous avoue qu'au début j'ai
eu un peu peur du choix qu'il a fait
pour l'introduire dans les comics Adam
Warlock a été conçu par des
scientifiques qui voulaient concevoir
une nouvelle forme de vie améliorée par
conséquent nous faisons face à la
naissance d'une sorte d'humain
génétiquement supérieur directement à un
âge adulte et c'est ça qui est pertinent
Adam Warlock quand il sort de son cocon
pour la première fois c'est un golem il
ne comprend absolument rien nous
interactions sociales il ne comprend pas
le bien et le mal il n'a aucune
éducation il n'a aucune expérience de la
vie bref vous avez compris du coup le
film a quand même été très précis dans
son adaptation on retrouve tout ça le
Adam du MCU est un civilisé il ne
comprend rien à ce qu'on lui dit il fait
n'importe quoi mais là la différence
c'est qu'ils ont joué sur le côté enfant
capricieux et surpuissant entre
guillemets car Adam Warlock est un peu
l'élu des souverains créé par le maître
de l'évolution d'ailleurs ils ont amené
le concept que Warlock est une création
du maître de l'évolution et là encore
c'est une belle référence au comics en
plus de simplifier l'histoire à l'époque
des premières apparitions d'Adam Warlock
les dessinateurs ne savaient pas du tout
quoi faire de ce personnage ils étaient
un peu perdus et pour lui trouver une
direction ils vont faire un comics un
peu spécial où ils vont tenter de nous
proposer une nouvelle aventure le
concernant et si ça plaît aux fans et
bien il développeront par la suite et
cette fameuse aventure est bien c'est le
moment où Adam Warlock va rencontrer le
Maître de l'évolution et le comics va
bien marcher pour beaucoup de fans c'est
vraiment à partir de ce moment ou Adam
Warlock va naître et le mot est
important car grâce à ce comics c'est
effectivement une nouvelle naissance
pour le personnage et sachant que le
maître de l'évolution est celui qui va
le prendre sous son aile et bien cela
accentue son côté divin mais voilà je ne
vais pas trop m'étaler là-dessus si vous
voulez en savoir plus et connaître
l'histoire d'Adam worlock je vous invite
à voir ma vidéo dédiée aux personnages
pourquoi Adam Warlock et si unique
communauté également les références
bibliques dans le film reliées à Adam
Warlock dont notamment la création
d'Adam de Michel-Ange et le moment où
nous avons la pression kadam Warlock
porte une sorte de toge avec son habit
déchiré c'est tout simplement car dans
l'univers des comics Adam Warlock c'est
un peu le prophète de Marvel et sachant
la place que prend le maître de
l'évolution dans l'histoire du
personnage et bien la thématique du
divin est quelque chose de très central
le concernant mais bon allez voir ma
vidéo sur l'histoire d'Adam Warlock pour
tout comprendre et voir sa relation avec
le maître de l'évolution enfin terminons
sur les scènes post-générique et la fin
que nous a proposé le film car il y a
des choses à dire déjà nous retrouvons
une nouvelle équipe pour les gardiens et
Adam Warlock en fait partie c'était la
suite logique je vous avoue étant donné
que nous savions que l'équipe actuelle
des gardiens allait s'arrêter pour nous
en proposer une nouvelle et vu qu'Adam
Warlock a fait partie longtemps des
gardiens dans les comics voilà on s'y
attendait un petit peu c'est d'ailleurs
quelques théories en tête concernant le
personnage pour la suite des événements
et je suis assez impatient de vous
partager tout ça toujours dans l'équipe
des gardiens on retrouve la petite fille
qui servait de nouvelles formes de vie
génétiquement améliorées par le maître
de l'évolution au début je vous avoue
que quand je l'ai aperçu j'ai totalement
buggé car je me suis dit quoi qu'est-ce
que cette fille fait dans l'équipe des
gardiens en plus elle a des pouvoirs
elle semble puissantes je me demandais
mais c'était qui je ne voyais pas du
tout qui c'était ce personnage et en
plus au vu de son physique une jeune
fille avec des longs cheveux blonds j'ai
cru que c'était Black Swan pour les
connaisseurs en gros c'est un personnage
de Secret Wars donc ça serait parti
quand même un peu loin si c'était ça
mais au final c'est pas du tout le cas
et après vérification il s'agit d'une
adaptation de filavel alors je vais pas
vous mentir je suis pas un expert du
personnage mais il semblerait quand même
que Marvel nous est proposé ici en plus
d'une adaptation une fusion en fait
filavel est né à cause d'une sorte de
manipulation temporelle normalement le
un personnage d'origine c'est jennis vel
et le suffixe veille devrait vous mettre
sur la piste il s'agit en gros d'un cri
et plus précisément jennis est l'enfant
d'un super soldat cri et il a été
génétiquement amélioré donc voilà cela
concorde quand même pas mal avec
l'adaptation du MCU et du coup pour
revenir à philavel qui d'ailleurs a fait
partie des gardiens c'est suite à la
reconstruction de l'univers qu'elle
apparaît c'est en gros une nouvelle
version de Jenny velle c'est pourquoi je
parle de fusion pour le MCU ce qui est
intéressant la concernant c'est que
c'est une cri je pense que Marvel a
prévu quelque chose concernant ce peuple
à l'avenir car Miss Marvel nous a ramené
subtilement l'écrit les gardiens nous
introduit de nouveau une crise avoir si
le MCU suit les comics mais je trouve ça
bizarre qu'elle soit dénommée en tant
que filavel si Marvel ne voulait pas
relier la jeune fille au cri je suppose
personnellement qu'ils auraient enlevé
le suffixe vel donc donc cela peut
potentiellement nous donner d'ailleurs
quelques théories à faire concernant le
maître de l'évolution si les enfants
sauvés sont finalement d'origine crie
mais bref et du coup bah on a the Marvel
ce qui arrive et qui va complètement
développer les cris donc je trouve ça
plutôt curieux et on en reparlera en
vidéo soyez sûr enfin concernant star
Lord il n'y a pas de véritablement
grande ouverture pour moi mais le fait
que Marvel est quand même terminé son
film des gardiens de la galaxie 3 qui
possèdent beaucoup de personnages sur le
légendaire star Lord reviendra cela tise
quand même quelque chose et c'est quand
même intéressant car maintenant star
Lord est sur terre donc je pense que
c'est pour proposer un nouveau souffle
pour le personnage évidemment et le
faire se développer un peu plus en solo
mais surtout bah sur terre il y a les
Avengers donc je sens quand même la
collaboration à venir et voilà on ne va
pas se mentir mais il se passe tout le
temps des dinguerie sur terre donc que
il sera forcément touché au bout d'un
moment et cela va le rapprocher avec les
Avengers il pourra même nous proposer
d'ailleurs quelques caméos pourquoi pas
mais en tout cas voilà il y aura
l'occasion d'en reparler mais en réalité
Marvel et 100% libre concernant Queen à
partir de maintenant ils peuvent lui
faire prendre n'importe quel direction
des armées et d'ailleurs petit détail
que je rajoute à la fin de la vidéo car
j'ai oublié mais j'ai trouvé ça quand
même assez étonnant que quill et réussi
à survivre dans l'espace un court
instant alors que ce n'est normalement
pas possible est-ce que cela peut
vouloir dire qu'il a toujours des
aptitudes de Céleste en lui nous verrons
normalement ça ne devrait pas être le
cas comme ça a été dit dans les gardiens
2 donc peut-être que je m'emballe mais
je voulais le signaler comme ça car j'ai
trouvé ça assez étonnant sur ce je pense
que l'on va s'arrêter là comme je vous
ai dit j'ai trouvé le film vraiment
incroyable c'était un Marvel vraiment de
qualité ils ont en plus fait briller
tous les personnages des gardiens je
trouve dans le film et c'était un pari
plutôt risqué quand même et je suis
content aussi qu'il n'y ait pas une mort
en vrai il n'y a pas toujours besoin
d'avoir des morts à la fin du film des
au revoir ou des adieux c'est tout aussi
puissant et en plus je trouve que c'est
un procédé assez intéressant car les
personnages sont toujours là en fait
cela laisse une porte ouverte pour des
futurs caméos pourquoi pas ou un même
impossible retour bref j'espère que la
vidéo vous aura plu j'étais très content
de vous parler des gardiens de la
galaxie volume 3 et me poser avec vous
pour partager autour de notre passion
commune je vous encourage à voir ma
vidéo sur Adam Warlock je vous le dis là
comme ça mais c'est un personnage sur
lequel je mise beaucoup pour l'avenir du
MCU et on va faire plein de théories de
concernant n'oubliez pas le petit pouce
bleu n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit
commentaire pour dire ce que vous avez
pensé du film je suis très curieux de
vous lire par rapport à ça d'ailleurs et
puis abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour ne
pas louper les prochaines vidéos voilà
cet état de rock que le lion hard soit
avec vous allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]